Lydia is with us in Indianapolis hi
Lydia welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave thanks for having me on sure what's
up in your world I just want a question
for you I'm a newlywed and me and my
husband got married by a year and a half
ago we went through the Financial Peace
University right after we got married
and I was about a year ago
thank you we attended a weird situation
where my husband brought in about 26,000
dollars in student loans to the marriage
I didn't bring in any student loans and
I was just wondering we we usually take
about one vacation a year and one
mission trip a year and we raise all the
money for ourselves
and I was just wondering we're really
having a hard time kind of chipping away
our debt and I would still want to keep
going on vacations with the time that he
has off but I don't know if that's
what's holding us back from I guess
making any progress is our debt and we
just it's kind of like it's never
getting any smaller even really put the
minimum payment every month so just
wondering what your vice was on that
well obviously you're going to have to
find some money to pay more on the debt
for it to go away aren't you mm-hmm
that's kind of you can make make $72,000
a year so it should it doesn't make
sense that we're not able to get more
time if you want that to go away the
obvious answer is we have to find some
money to put onto the debt that you're
not putting on the debt now oh
something's got to go for the student
loan to go Oh what do you want what do
you want how about what are you willing
to SEC what are you willing to sacrifice
to get rid of your student loans it's so
hard so far it's been nothing nothing so
far you're willing to sacrifice nothing
you got married in your living your
little life with your picket fence in
your mission strips and your freakin
vacations and you're normal and you got
student loans and sitting there like you
think it's a pet so far you've
sacrificed nothing yeah so do we just
need to cut back on our spending every
month to get creative extra towards it
out you think
and maybe the vacation and maybe the
missions trip yeah this is not a
lifetime sentence it's saying hey we're
going to live for a period of time we're
going to roll up our sleeves and go
crazy we're gonna sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next we're going to
cut our dadgum spending down to nothing
we're going to be on beans and rice rice
and beans our date night is a frisbee in
the park we are getting out of debt and
you do that for a short period of time
and then voila you get rid of $26,000 in
one year while making seventy five
thousand and you get your life back the
borrower is slave to the lender you're
feeling the chains of slavery wrapped
around your throat right now aren't you
yeah and we don't know how much worse I
mean we want to pay it off eventually
but we don't know how much versus pay
for months to really like you know get
it down because because we want to
budget for things like you know crude
and the rent and everything like that
food and rent you can do it but food and
rent you can do but I think an extra job
and selling some things and cutting
everything else in your life to the
bare-bones and $2,000 a month makes us
go away in 13 months 26 divided by 2
that was hard that's what you're gonna
have to do you're not going to get out
of debt until you get mad about being in
debt right now it's just kind of like
okay
but you're going to have to get ticked
off and when you get ticked off you can
break the orbital pull of stupid let
stupid has an orbital pull it's got a
gravitational pull to it and the way you
break that you expend energy you have to
get passionate get fired up hey I'm the
same way I'm no different than you no
better no worse just older and uglier
this is the Dave Ramsey show